i'm married to this state and i would
eat this every day
she's married to the steak hey everybody
i'm anthony prosky and i'm going to be
reviewing not one but two recipes of
mine that were featured on celebrity
recipe guaya
is french for royale let's go first up
my steak recipe so here we have auntie
porrovsky's steak recipe i know this has
nothing to do with the recipe but i'm
sometimes the simplest thing to get me
really excited i just realized that that
mixing bowl has a rubber base so that it
doesn't slide now i need to quickly find
out
where
that bowl was purchased because i think
that's amazing okay anyway i'm back i'm
focusing steak recipe got it so anthony
marinates the steak with some crushed
garlic and some thinly sliced ginger
not a critique of the technique peeling
ginger i used to use a knife all the
time but it actually wastes a lot of the
ginger root my friend rima's mom taught
me that you should use the edge of the
spoons because it scrapes off all of
like the fibers from the outside like
that rough skin and it leaves you with a
lot more fresh ginger to use while
that's marinating we're going to chop up
our herbs and our jalapeno for garnish
we're going to chip a nod parsley basil
and mint and throw it in a bowl along
with some thinly sliced jalapenos
he throws in two halves of the lime in
the pan for a little extra if you're
right i do throw lime halves into the
pan because you need the skins in there
as well there's a lot of really good
citrus oils on the plate he toughed it
off with a shallow vinaigrette the herbs
jalapenos and the juice of the two
roasted limes beautiful
hangers
you can see when you
cook the lime hops with the steak in the
cast iron skillet more juice comes out
of the wine this one looks delicious it
looks like maybe a carne asada something
you would get at a taqueria this is very
yummy
yeah it has a little kick
definitely my kind of cut i love rare
and i love medium rare i love red medium
rare too
married to this state and i would eat
this every day
she's married to the steak people seem
to be appreciating like the mixture of
the different herbs that's one thing
that i learned
in antony in the kitchen my first
cookbook that i worked really hard on
with mindy shameless plug for it
and to me let's do dinner i continue to
mix herbs together and a lot of recipes
in that book but anyways that's neither
here or there we're here to look at
steak free was definitely my favorite i
love
pickled onions i love the jalapeno it
just added that extra kick and it was i
love pickled shallots too
number four the taste was there for me i
liked how it was cooked
gordon ramsay
fair my favorite out of these four
dishes was number three it tasted
super fresh it was really nice and
tender
it is really tender so i guess the
judges enjoyed their steaks makeover
because anthony porowski takes today's
celebrity steak challenge i won yes
now i'll be watching my grilled cheese
recipe he uses brioche in his recipe and
he starts off by curving
so here's the deal adding mayo to each
slice of bread
you don't even really taste it when it's
there but it just acts as a really good
binder if you're putting something like
any type of ham or prosciutto or a
varico or whatever it is it just allows
it to cling more easily so that when you
first put your grilled cheese onto a
really hot pan it's not just gonna all
kind of like slide off it acts as a
really good binder then he tosses that
into a very well buttered pan very well
butter
slice it diagonally he insists and here
we have anthony perovski's grilled
cheese cutting grilled cheese diagonally
does taste better there's just something
so satisfying because if you cut it as
like a rectangle when you bite into it
it just makes it harder to get like more
of it in your mouth but if you cut it
diagonal if you start with a point it
goes deeper into your mouth and you're
able to get a larger bite
i feel like for this one the cheese
didn't have that much time to melt
before the
bread got a little too brown the thing
about grilled cheese is that the cheese
has to be completely melted the cheeses
that melted on this grilled cheese and
it's kind of like a trigger for me if
she put it on slightly lower heat
the cheese would have been able to melt
the bread was really nice and cold but
if she would have kept it longer then
the bread would have burnt and cheese
wouldn't have been ready i like the
prosciutto i don't think that it's
necessary but it's a good sandwich that
was a bummer the steak made me really
happy but the grilled cheese kind of
made me a little sad
thank you so much for watching september
14th
my second cookbook anthony let's do
dinner it's all about
dinner so please support and
really excited for you to cook from it
hopefully queer eye coming out we don't
really know when because memphis doesn't
tell us anything but it'll be out soon
[Music]